i guess stuff happens oh yeah that was
the other thing i got all distracted
with on vacation so i stepped in
like a big nice internet drama pile and
then literally boarded a plane
moments later yeah i saw that i saw that
i i saw that you got involved in the
whole nicole arbour
louis louis j gomez so yeah
most of you guys have been following us
but there are plenty of people that
watch us that don't follow us in that
realm but um so louis j gomez
uh a guy we've had nice things to say
about on the show
gas digital network which we've had
nothing but nice things to say about
we've had the owner ralph on our show
when we're in miami
we've had uh bronx johnny from brooklyn
i thought we had chris from brooklyn
also we never got bronx johnny on we
keep saying hey we're gonna come on and
he got busy he's got something we're
chris from bro you're right we didn't
meet chris from brooklyn uh ralph uh
you know and we've there have been times
we've goofed on them they've been other
type of we never you know we just always
plug them because
right there we very much respect what
they've done they've done
they've succeeded where many people have
failed uh they're no compound
they've had multi-million dollars that's
the phrase the kids are saying
uh they you know they've managed to
band together and create something that
look we leave an event we try to network
it failed miserably because
that's a lot of moving parts and a lot
of people to control it's not easy
uh so they did a good job with that um
they've been defending comedy
relentlessly the shane gillis stuff
louis ck um all that good [ __ ] so
they've been
pretty much the way i told it to louis
was uh you know basically it's like a
few people left that are just
keeping comedy on a respirator and
everybody else is just out there like oh
i was
let me tell you like everything is just
uh guys i want to take a moment to talk
about police brutality
uh and they're the only ones that have
been doing that so louis j gomez uh on
his real ass podcast had a uh youtuber
by the name of nicole arboron who i've
never heard of before this have you ever
do you ever yes and i'll tell you but
let me tell you from where okay
she was one of those uh pumped facebook
videos
that but i never would consider her a
comic or anything it was one of those
uh based like actually let me tell you
why fat shaming's awesome
one of those so basically she was trying
to be like an e
but like a right-wing dude but then the
attention i saw was dwindling and i saw
that then she had a quick
turnaround especially on the me too
stuff where she was like the me too
stuff is stupid
and you all deserve to now it's like i
want to apologize
for anybody i heard in the me too
movement
and you deleted a lot of tweets nicole
which is kind of weird it's very weird
when you
become woke and then like 7 500 tweets
disappear
it's a little odd uh but this this is
the new mo for these people so
uh phil's been on crowder apparently
some people are saying i heard that a
lot too
um she's basically like if you guys go
back you can watch the real ass podcast
episodes
you can watch the night wave take on it
i hate both of those shows she went into
the real ass podcast
louis jake gomez was doing his usual
thing a new hot chick in the room and
he's doing the whole pepe le pew
of course you know i'm gonna hit on you
and of course i'm gonna fail miserably
on the air because it's funny for
content and
she brought her own camera person which
right away red flag right there that is
a red when you bring your own camera
person that's a problem yeah
and uh she so she filmed it from her
perspective so she could use the footage
um without getting a hit you know it's
very smart very smart right um
they it was awkward it wasn't a great
appearance uh she's not funny
you know she's just a youtuber who
thinks she's a comedian so
um didn't it wasn't the best episode
ever that they did
and then she left nothing was said and
then
an hour goes by she has a new video up
on instagram and youtube
uh you know what is it comedian destroys
sexist comedy club uh comedy festival
owner or whatever
and uh she cut it up she you know
tweaked the footage and made him
and even in the tweaked footage he still
came off more likeable but that was uh
during that whole fray uh we covered it
on nightwave and i said some
less than flattering things about her um
about her fading looks about the fact
that her last movie was in 2011
and um is the skin's not holding up like
it used to all kinds of mean stuff
and uh well now we're we're lewis j
gomez followed me
so that's pretty talking and uh yeah we
might uh we're trying to
figure something out to maybe go up
there and do some stuff but uh
this woman is horrendous she's
flip-flopped more times on anything i've
ever seen
um she's copyright striking channels
see that you know all the other stuff is
again there's
a lot of but then you start doing that
like that is like that's when you're
like the lowest of the low like
that's the dregs that that's the dregs
of like i'm gonna actually
copyright strike channels like there's
certain people that we've goofed on and
we've really goofed on them hard
but they've never like done [ __ ] moves
like the [ __ ] like what owen did or what
baked alaska did you know and be like oh
we're going to copyright strike your
channel now
that is just some low levels
grimy some grimy i don't want people to
hear what i said because it makes me
look bad
[ __ ] i really hate that i hate when
anybody does that
and i and i dared this to hit my channel
and she has yet to hit nightwave
for anything although i i paused it so
much
and only played little snippets because
she's so hateable i couldn't make it
more than
a half a second every time i would
unpause and she would say one thing and
i'd be like
it was like 40 minutes of yelling so i
don't think she's going to be able to
hit me anyway because it's
all me did someone says she sued theo
for headphones that hurt her
another thing i heard uh that i didn't
hear this one this is new for me so so
what is this the story is i don't know
but enough people are
kind of saying it's true so i don't know
if it's true but a lot of people are
saying it is she was on theo von's [ __ ]
podcast and she tried to sue him
before i think her earring got caught on
his headphones
that's not her though no no if you know
what if you know if you know anything
about rape you know like
women that do radio whether they're
terrible in their holes and they're
whatever
they know oh i can't wear super dangly
earrings if we just know there's certain
things or if you do you ask for the
earbud headphones to put in that's on
you yeah all right can i just now i got
to do the theo
impression yeah man it's just like you
know i thought back to it and it's like
you know like maybe my headphones could
have been better
you know maybe uh maybe i could have
been a nicer person i don't know
it's like oh yeah theo always just even
when it's not his fault he's just like
guilt-ridden and feels bad
maybe i just could have been a better
person about it i don't know man maybe
she's right
no theo stand up for yourself stick up
for yourself one time yeah so this is so
so the word is on the latest episode
with bobby this is from a year ago by
the way so this is a year ago this was
written
on the latest episode with bobby lee
theowen said a female comic tried
filing a lawsuit over her malfunction
with her headphones
who wasn't and most people are saying uh
nicole arbour for sure
nicole uh
i guess the way he said it there wasn't
a lot of females that were on recently
and they narrowed down that it wasn't
whitney cummings because he's been on
his show again
you know yeah and that's that's usually
yeah and they're because they know
each other that's a different thing
right like whitney cummings is another
comedy store person and so theos they
would
i i don't think whitney cummings would
have sued theo for a headphone thing i
think that she probably would have made
fun of theo for 10 minutes about a a
headphone thing
right so it had to be yeah it's this
woman has got a
long history of being an opportunistic
little slime ball joy of pessy worked uh
he says he worked with her as a
as a editor or something on a video she
did
she did these horrible rap videos a
couple years like she's cringe as [ __ ]
wasn't she topless in a movie too i
think yeah that clip going around
yeah yeah she uh nice tits yeah pretty
decent tits
i mean i don't want a 12-hour ban from
twitter like you got but word he says
all right no i get look let's be honest
she can still get it i get it but that
milk's been sitting on the shelf for
eight years all right but some people
like cheese
i like cheese [ __ ] but i don't
like mold [ __ ] free
yeah seriously so uh she's but she just
has a history of doing this [ __ ]
that she was topless in a 2011 jason
muse horror film
that was made in canada so it's all done
for
it's been if this is him snoogans
oh [ __ ] um
so i i've i haven't seen the back and
forth of them going i thought they
talked for a second and they worked it
out for a sec
but then it just ramped up again
she doesn't learn no so she like yeah i
guess the the now
the thing is he called her or she said
call me they worked out a phone call
situation she goes fine i'll take the
vegan
because louis is only only demand has
been take that [ __ ] video down like
this is stupid you know and she's like
i'll take it down
but i want an hour broadcast you and me
will both film it and
[ __ ] you and louis just kind of was like
if i whatever just take the video down
i'll do it
and then [ __ ] wouldn't do that lewis
jay gomez like the next day he tweeted
he goes
all right guys uh so i'm gonna i'm gonna
do an hour with her
broadcasting uh she's gonna take the
video down we're gonna work something
out man it's gonna be cool and he just
got bombarded with
dude [ __ ] this like you're bigger than
her
stop this this is none of us want to see
her you shouldn't put yourself in a
position to be in that [ __ ] room with
her again
she's going to pull this [ __ ] again look
at this track record stop it and lewis
finally like
an hour goes by he pulls a pewdiepie and
he's like oh yeah after uh some
careful consideration i talked to a
couple people i'm not gonna do that
so she put it back up so now they've
been fighting non-stop still like cats
and dogs for
for a couple of days now it's been
pretty funny it's been like a funny
distraction
while i've been on vacation like because
you know it's like when we go on
vacation it sucks
people are always trying to start drama
with us that's like come on man
i know he's like i know dude i just want
to eat shrimp cocktail and be with my
wife
you know that was the same way i'm just
like there come on and uh
so it was just nice to somebody else's
beef and i'm like oh this is beautiful
man there's no emotional attachment
uh i did get a 12-hour ban as roy's
pointed out for complimenting her saying
she had nice tits and she does does she
not have nice tits are we not allowed to
compliment the female form
apparently not so uh yeah
from what i see about her she's there's
a couple things that are kind of off
uh i mean i'm sure you covered a bunch
of this stuff but it's kind of weird to
have 438 000 subs but only get like 50
000 views it's kind of weird
she averages 20 to 30 likes on tweets
yeah
i'm looking at youtube but yeah oh but
but she has 500 000 or something
if you go look at her twitter i can't
remember it's 50 000 or 500 that she has
a lot of paid followers and then
she gets the same impressions that you
and i get
on twitter and i'm not even talking
about the rotc account i'm talking about
personal
our personal dumb accounts um she's got
she definitely has bought followers um
if you guys google
uh caroline callaway she was a um
she was an instagram influencer uh and
her ghostwriter just came out and a huge
story against her
a couple months like maybe a month ago a
couple weeks ago and
she kind of paints a really accurate
picture of how these
uh sort of manufactured come to
prominence
and how they always have like some dumpy
looking girl that looks like daria
writing for them
and doing all their you know material
and stuff but uh
they buy followers like it was google
caroline callaway
read that art not you but i'm saying you
guys later and read that article it'll
tell you
everything i'm gonna do that instead of
the show okay that's fine quietly
click click click occasional
coffee yeah no but that's it but yeah so
if you look that up this this uh
this of course he'll have no woman like
a fury like a woman scoring so this
female best be old bff of caroline
callaway came out and was like
here is a road map or carraway somebody
think don't talk [ __ ] about cap calloway
not not cab calloway don't
but fine but just press f to pay your
respects to captain galloway i mean
that's a long time ago let's set up that
rule eddie wade
no disrespect of cab calloway on our
show you heard me that's
the first and only rule yes in this
community
um but yeah so this daria looking [ __ ]
came out and
gave you guys an entire road map on how
women like this
even can can pretend
that they're important even though
they're not yeah
so yeah she was basically trying to stir
up a me too thing is what she was doing
she was trying it was she's trying to
garner attention but did you see her
tweets about
well if you don't want to get don't get
drunk yeah stop being
deleted a lot man all like no but
they're trust me there's plenty of
people out there that have been saving
them
uh they're not gonna go away and she's
been around for long enough too that
i'm sure people have that [ __ ] archived
on wayback machines so it's not going
away
um every time this tries to get it's
really funny it's like watching a fight
where somebody just keeps getting back
off and it's just right bam bam bam bam
she's gonna i don't know how many times
she's gonna keep getting back
up but uh stay down just stay down throw
in a towel be done with it i don't know
but
you know you got to understand with
people like this even though it's
negative attention it's still a tension
versus
the the dwindling attention she was
starting to get you know what i mean
so this keeps her in the spotlight and
i've actually seen
it's people that that i really don't
talk to whatever but somebody added me
on facebook
to one of this a group called please i
stay in it because it's
called comic mafia and it's basically i
swear to god
and they added me to it because of how
cringe it was but it's just a group on
facebook where it's a bunch of comics
and you know doing comic things and god
the future looks bad for comedy
but there was a couple women going can
you believe this loser louis j
gomez is going after nicole art but i'm
like are you [ __ ] are you
serious are you first off she's not a
comic
she's not even funny no she's just
that they manufactured into being based
yeah
she's a lauren southern without the
[ __ ] pride to retire
yeah you know go like to hey clock's a
ticket i'm about to hit the big 3-0 i
better
[ __ ] mosey on out here yeah and say
we went about lauren southern that [ __ ]
had balls
you know what i mean she didn't [ __ ]
[ __ ] foot around at a fence ride this
woman's flip-flopped all the time lauren
southern was just like mulatto balls but
balls
you gotta do yeah that's true uh but
yeah so she's uh
i think she's i think it's gonna die
down we're gonna see what the only thing
i don't like about this woman is that
she claims to be a comedian she claims
to like comedy and all this right
she's trying to harm like
a brand that's one of the last
flourishing independent
comedy brands like the skanks the legion
of skanks
and i know some a lot of our fans love
the legion of skanks some people hate
the legends gangs
even if you hate their [ __ ] guts
they're the only like one of the only
organized organizations that has a
festival
has a whole network of podcasts and
they're trying to keep
comedy on a [ __ ] respirator and the
so-called comics are like
shut it down and it's like why are you
trying to harm their sponsors and go
after their [ __ ] when
it's you're not gonna have a lot of uh
these venues left if you keep this up
comedy's had this big woke revolution
that's been going on for a while and it
really is
like you know before even
go back to the tough crowd days for
example right where where there was
there was this real next little there
was a sweet spot we hit where it was
just
comics being brutal and funny but you
could say whatever you want but comics
up until very recently even if they
hated another comic
they always like defended him like hey
he's a comma hey you know what
i might not like jeff foxworthy he might
be a hack but did you def you know you
dealt with the philippines
laura would be defending jeff fox
correct
he was joking okay yeah so so there was
always this
we're going to defend each other no
matter no matter what you know
even if you're a piece of [ __ ] we've
done it we've defended shows that we
[ __ ]
hate you know because you you can't
root for somebody else to get destroyed
by something could easily destroy you
even if you hate them
but now you see verified comics
that are going after other comics and
it's like this is going to destroy your
whole thing
you you you guys have no loyalty to the
industry that [ __ ] some dudes went to
jail to build you know what i mean like
there's a reason why magneto and
professor x teamed up whenever
apocalypse showed up because
it's like look man i you know i get it i
get it but damn
this guy could we just do this real
quick but we'll go back to fighting but
after this and also after like the shane
gillis thing like stuff like that you
start realizing like
man some of you [ __ ] comics are
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you think that destroying the industry
you're in is going to do anything
[ __ ] stop it it is i think it's one
of the most disgusting things that's
been going on
i think it's almost like the
entertainment world equivalent of
accelerationism it's like the people
that want to
accelerate the complete collapse of the
system so that
something else you know grows out of it
that's better than what we have
and there are people that actually think
that way and i think there's people that
think that way in terms of
the entertainment industry too it's like
i don't care
who gets hurt in the process if like
i'm not doing well in the current system
so maybe if we blow the whole system up
and kill a bunch of people
something else will grow out of it where
i get to be a winner
but the problem is is that even when
that happens
you're not going to be a winner you
don't have a killer instinct you don't
have that
that [ __ ] drive to to to something
with yourself so even if the system does
collapse
nicole arbour ain't rising out of the
ashes you know it's going to be new up
and coming guys so and by the way i'm
not saying you can't [ __ ] make fun of
other comments you can't if they suck if
there's um that's not what we're talking
about
talking about like for example we made
fun of sarah weinshank
we've never said she should be canceled
she shouldn't be booked at any club she
should
there's there's a difference between
calling out people that are [ __ ]
hacks or whatever
but it's usually the other way around
you'll defend people like that but then
when it's your turn in the barrel when
you're a misogynistic pig they either
sit there with their mouths [ __ ]
closed
or they go you know what [ __ ] them they
represent the worst it's in comedy
it's like [ __ ] you man there's a way to
get your point across without absolutely
making
costing somebody their [ __ ]
livelihood you know
over jokes by the way we're not talking
about someone [ __ ]
helping they should lose their
livelihood you should be fired you
should work on people like that right
but for telling jokes
it's it to me it's it's absolutely
it's a [ __ ] disgrace what's been
going on in comedy and
if you would have told me and look i
like luigi gomez but if you would have
told me 10 years ago
when louie was making jokes on the
bennington show or ron and fez
do you think i would have said he's
going to be one of the last dudes that's
actually
i would have never thought that but
here's where we are now yeah there's
only a few people
like no [ __ ] you not only that but like
the fact that he like actually owns a
brand yeah exactly yeah jesus chris
lewis j gomez
yeah it's impressive that just goes to
show you guys that when you're dumb as
rocks and you come from a poor
background
as long as you're a hard-working you can
still own your own
muffler oh sorry
there is what i'm used to right here
there is something about dumb
that just they all become business
owners through sheer will
i'll just work 70 hours a week it's fine
and it's like well you're going to beat
everybody eventually
it's there last one out of the office
dudes
so you [ __ ] go to go to miami right
now you i dare you to find me an hvac
company that doesn't have a hispanic and
owner